there are more than a trillion galaxies
in the universe and my team discovered
an extremely rare one a galaxy that
doesn't look quite like anything
observed before this galaxy is so
peculiar that it challenges our theories
and our assumptions about how the
universe works the majority of the
galaxies are spiral similar to our own
Milky Way
we have strong theories about how these
common galaxies form and evolve but we
don't understand how rare galaxies form
and evolve and especially puzzling rare
case is hog's object it has a very
symmetric central body surrounded by a
circular r2 ring with nothing visible
connecting that rock-type galaxies are
among the rarest types of galaxies
currently known they are fewer than one
in 1,000 galaxies it's a mystery how the
stars in the outer ring are just
floating there in such an orderly manner
that's interesting right hold on
things are about to get more mysterious
the galaxies that my team discovered is
even rarer and much more complex than
that you know sometimes you search and
search for these objects and you find
nothing but sometimes it just appears in
the background then you are not even
looking for it this system looks very
similar to hog the object with its
central body and circular art ring we
got very excited and thought we
discovered another hogs object but my
research showed this is an entirely new
galaxy type now commonly refer to as
poochie's galaxy
we will be we will not be visiting this
galaxy anytime soon it is approximately
359 million light years away from Earth
you may think this is far well actually
this is one of the nearby galaxies I
study this object in different light in
ultraviolet optical and near-infrared II
like a scar or wrinkles tell the story
of our lives
similarly a galaxy structure in
different light can help us trace back
their origin and evolution how do I look
for these details I model the bright
central body I remove my model from the
image to check for any hidden features
because a bright structure in a galaxy
may blind our views of faint features
just like using sunglasses when you are
blinded by the intense light the result
was a big surprise
this galaxy doesn't just have an outer
ring it has an additional diffuse inner
ring we were having a hard time
explaining the origin of the outer ring
in hog-tied galaxies now we also need to
explain this mysterious second ring
there is currently no known mechanism
that can explain the existence of an
inner ring in such a peculiar galaxy so
the discovery of purchased galaxies
clearly highlights the gap in our
knowledge of galaxy evolution further
research into how this extremely rare
galaxy was formed can provide us with
new clues on how the universe works
this discovery tells us that we still
have a lot to learn and we should keep
looking deeper at different space and
keep searching for the unknown thank you
[Applause]